animals plants microbes live in a world
that's constantly changing
it can be as simple as a drop of water
where the temperature is going up if you
happen to be a one cell paramecium or an
amoeba it can be an entire ecosystem and
what we're experiencing now is climate
change over the long term
and a tremendous amount of study is
going on as to how animals adapt to
these kinds of things
homeostasis are built in mechanisms that
allow organisms to regulate their
internal environment within certain
ranges there are different kinds of
animals that will regulate very narrowly
things like potassium and sodium and
chloride inside of their bodies and
other kinds of animals such as certain
kinds of fish that'll allow it to vary
pretty widely there are some organisms
that will maintain their internal
environment very very different from the
external environment
and there are other animals that will be
able to live just quite comfortably by
keeping their insides pretty much
similar to what's on the outside
so homeostasis as a concept is the
ability of an organism to regulate
something about its internal composition
to some degree
you encounter homeostasis every day in
your life
you're regulating your own body
temperature
all right as an example you're not
familiar with it but your kidneys are
very carefully regulating the amount of
chloride and sodium in your blood and
when those things go out of kilder what
what results is various kinds of disease
the concept is probably most easily
understood just by what you do in your
house
when you're trying to regulate the
temperature of your house a thermostat
is really designed to homeostatically
regulate the temperature for your house
at the temperature you want it to be at
and so what it's able to do is to
recognize when the temperature Falls
below what you've set particularly in
the winter and to turn on mechanisms to
bring it back to where you would set it
which is in scientific terms it's called
the set point
homeostasis has a lot to do with the
concept called feedback
and there are two basic kinds of
feedback called positive feedback and
negative feedback
so in positive feedback what happens is
that if something deviates
from what the desired level is that
causes
greater and greater and greater
deviation away from that original set
point
an example of positive feedback in an
organism would be the case of Labor as
labor approaches the brain has
mechanisms that produces a hormone
called oxytocin which causes the uterus
to contract pushes the baby forward
their receptors in the cervix of the
uterus at the base that send signals
back to the base that it's being
stretched as the baby's head is moving
there which causes more oxytocin to be
released and therefore greater
contraction until the baby is expelled
in negative feedback what happens is
that the system detects a deviation in
some direction from the desired level or
that set point and what it does is that
it works to bring the system back so
that it's at that level of the set
points so for example in the pancreas
the the beta cells detect levels of
blood glucose and when there are surges
in in blood glucose after you've just
eaten meal or if you've been fasting for
a long time and blood glucose levels go
down there are a whole series of
chemical nervous and hormonal reactions
after that change is detected that
attempt to bring the blood glucose level
either up if it's too low if you're
hypoglycemic or to bring it down if
you're hyperglycemic and therefore to
keep blood glucose within a very very
narrow range right when we think about
homeostasis in other words maintaining
things within a narrow limit there are a
couple things that an organism can do it
can respond to a change that's already
happened and bring the system back after
that changes occurred or that's called
negative feedback or it can anticipate
that A change is likely to occur and
begin to to take steps to alleviate or
mitigate the problem before it actually
happens and a perfect example is the
regulation of body temperature in in
mammals as an example of what's called
negative feed forward it brings the
system back to where it was but it
anticipates it's a forward-looking
system rather than a responsive system a
feedback system
homeostasis is really an important
concept to understand it can happen
through interactions of the nervous
system the hormonal system
within cells across cells across
different organ systems there are so
many different levels of homeostasis
that are going on in different kinds of
organisms depending upon the thing
that's being regulated